oh my god he just farted guys
i'm embarrassed to be in front of all
these people what's up gq my name is
ella may and these are my essentials
first off we have my phone of course
i feel like in this generation and in
this 2020
if you can live without your phone you
are a very special person and i commend
you a lot because i
cannot live without my phone the number
one thing i do with my phone is facetime
i sometimes look at the time and be like
oh it's five o'clock where did the day
go and i've literally just been on
facetime
the whole day whether that's my mom to
my brother to my best friend in new york
i'm always on facetime it's terrible
actually so my second item is a diptype
candle
i actually only recently got put onto
diptych my brother put me on
but mustard actually really loves the
tea candles as well this is the vanilla
flavor my favorite one is actually the
amber one
which is being discontinued and going
out of stock so i'm very sad
they're quite strong in a sense of like
they'll leave even if i blow the candle
out i can still smell the candles but
they're not overbearing if they're still
subtle enough that you won't walk in my
house and think that there's like a
whole bunch of perfume
so they're subtle and strong at the same
time if that makes any sense
even just like being in their store it's
very clean it's very fresh
and your whole house will smell amazing
if you're going to dip tea
i should be a sales woman this next one
is the essential of all essentials in
elements world i promise you
wherever you go you will never not find
me
with five of these in my bag this is
burt bee's
moisturizing lip balm this one is the
coconut and pear one it's actually not
my favorite flavor
my favorite flavor is the vanilla bean
one which has a blue cap
but i promise you i have every single
flavor of burt's bees some people might
say it feels kind of
like it feels almost too thick because
obviously it's beeswax it's made out of
beeswax but i love everything the
company also stands for
they're very natural brand and it's very
very moisturizing and it smells good
it's subtle again it's a very subtle
scent
i literally can't live without it like i
one thing i really really hate
is dry lips if i'm speaking to someone
and they have dry lips it's the only
thing i can concentrate
on so i make sure that i never put
myself in that position
by moisturizing my lips please people
moisturize your lips and do it
with burt's bees you can find it in l7
this essential is my fenty beauty lip
gloss
as well as the burt's bees you always
have to be moisturized underneath your
lip gloss
but fenty beauty lip gloss is my
favorite everyday
lip gloss i don't really wear makeup um
i can't do it i will look like a clown
if i do it myself
so unless my lovely makeup artist is
with me
then you'll really only get like some
moisturizer and some
burt's bees and some fenty beauty out of
me it's not too
overpowering but it also gives you just
a little bit of
gloss other than the fact that it's
rihanna's lip gloss obviously and i love
her
there's a lot of shimmer which i think
she has on a lot of the fenty products
but it's a lot of shimmer but like i
said it's not overbearing so you don't
look like you just
rubbed your lips in car oil it actually
just gives you a little shine and a
little gloss and it's not sticky
and the packaging is super cute i'm a
sucker for some packaging like i'll
literally buy something if i like the
color of the packaging
my next one is this little charm
necklace
has a key on it and the key has the
number 21 on it
it has a r it has a t and it has an e
so my best friends got me this for my
21st birthday hence why there's a 21 on
the key
my best friends are called rebecca and
tamara so rt and e for ella
these are my best friends since i was
three years old i literally wear this
every day obviously i have on my 10
summers chain right now but that's
because i had to show you guys this but
on
every day unless i'm like going out and
i want to dress up
i will have this one this is my everyday
chain i think it gives me a piece of
home
since i don't live in england anymore
okay so this essential item
is probably very english of me these are
pg tips english breakfast tea bags
and all my english people watching this
video pg tips are better than tetley
thank you very much i drink tea every
morning
like a true londoner just a quick public
service announcement
on the pg tips because i use milk in my
tea in my english breakfast tea
if you're ever making me a cup of tea
you have to take the tea bag off before
you put the milk in
anybody who puts the milk in with
the tea bag in the cup is a serial
killer please do not do that that's not
the way it works
this item is some cmos i am jamaican my
grandparents are jamaican so this is
close to home um but i actually only
just started
using seymour it's very good for
everything hair
nails immune system all of that stuff
digestion
it's very very good this is already
boiled and obviously prepared and ready
to use i put it in my smoothies
and it also doesn't taste like anything
but i know you can also use this as a
face mask
my next essential is essential water the
over-achieving h2o
i know people say all water taste the
same it really doesn't
if all water tastes the same to you you
have not tasted essential oil it's
really my favorite i don't like to drink
anything else
if i have a choice of course and i try
to drink a lot of water especially when
i'm in the studio but even just
to keep my skin clear essential water
see water doesn't have flavor but
there's like some water that tastes like
toilet water
well i've never tasted toilet water so
i'm just being dramatic
i don't know what it is about this water
honestly i couldn't i couldn't tell you
i'm not selling it very well
but it's just it's just different it
makes me feel like i have superpowers
my next essential thank you this is
thierry
this is my two and a half year old
french bulldog who clearly does what he
wants
he doesn't listen which is why he's
halfway on this table and no you're not
getting on the table
he's a little bit camera shy clearly oh
there he goes
my dog is my essential because he's
really like this is gonna sound so sad
but he really is like my best friend
a lot of my friends don't live in l.a my
family doesn't live in la so he's my
little sense of like
just like a part of me almost his name
is thierry i named him after my favorite
football player soccer player american
people call it full tierion reed who is
actually french
and he is a french bulldog sometimes i
feel like he owns me and i don't own him
but this is really my friend
my prized possession if you want a
companion someone to like
just love and always have company and be
by your side
you should get a dog but it does require
a lot of patience i promise you he's
taught me a lot about patients because
i'm a very impatient person
my apple airpods are an essential i have
a frenchie
case on it this is thierry i don't
understand how anybody travels anywhere
or like doesn't have headphones i can't
live without them i have to listen to my
music
like i said to you i'm always on
facetime so i just have to make sure
no one's in my business no i'm just
kidding my airpods i literally i can't
go without
if i'm usually listening to music in
2020
it's either some unreleased lma or not
another love song my new single but if
it's not myself
to sound less egotistical i would say
some lauren hill i was listening to the
missed education of lauren hill this
morning or some bryson tiller
his new project there's a whole bunch of
r b to be honest
in these airports so that's a wrap on my
essentials thank you guys for watching
thank you gq for having me and i hope
you guys all stay safe
and go and check out my new single not
another love song